à saint germain en laye dans les
yvelines quand on est jeune et qu'on est
à la recherche d'un emploi il suffit de
s'adresser à patrick il s'occupe du
reste
alors on est prêt pour cette opération
sel de table on est à fond
patrick a fait imprimer des cv format
xxl les restaurants les utilisent comme
sets de table impossible de les manquer
et en plus les candidats sont à l'entrée
du restaurant leur mission faire bonne
impression
bien sûr ça ne marche pas à tous les
coups c'est dur mais la dernière fois
que patrick a fait ça cinq jeunes sur
dix ont décroché leur premier job faux
cv sur les sets de table alors voilà non
si jamais vous êtes intéressé vous
connaissez quelqu'un qui cherche vous
avez nos coordonnées vous nous appelez
tout de suite avec près de 4 millions de
chômeurs en france rechercher un emploi
ressemble bien souvent un vrai parcours
du combattant
le cv la bonne vieille lettre de
motivation reste bien sûr incontournable
j'envoie mes cv par internet mais lettre
de motivation ça va vite c'est rapide et
efficace tout son réseau et d'être
pistonné ce confetti a que ça qui marche
actuellement
mais quand on veut trouver le travail de
ses rêves certains sont prêts à tout
pour se faire remarquer la dernière
tendance
le cv en chanson je peux travailler je
suis un excellent chef de projet mais
aussi proposé de l'argent à un employeur
contre un cdi avec la crise quand il
faut se vendre tout est permis
j'avais alors jusqu'où certains sont ils
prêts à aller pour trouver un emploi est
ce que ça marche vraiment cette semaine
combien ça coûte l'hebdo vous dit tout
pour avoir la tête de l'emploi pour
décrocher son premier boulot
florence fait comme tout le monde
étudiante en journalisme elle passe
toutes ses journées devant son
ordinateur à envoyer des candidatures et
à répondre à des annonces plus de 220 cv
deux entretiens qui n'ont rien donné ça
ne mord pas vraiment tous les jours j'en
vois une dizaine de de réponse à des
annonces que je reçois rien il y a deux
mois
florence a décidé de se démarquer elle a
donc réalisé un court métrage inspiré du
film amélie poulain qu'elle a mises en
ligne sur internet
donc elle cherche un contrat
d'apprentissage en alternance de
journalisme culturel à paris ou pas loin
autour
elle vient de châlons-en-champagne et
elle est très intelligente
florence porcel m le doré la littérature
le jus d'orange
la théorie des cordes écrire et des
haricots c'est drôle et ça cartonne
soixante mille personnes ont vu sa
demande d'emploi pour le moins atypique
et la vidéo le défaite en une semaine
avec les cours avec ma vie à côté enfin
voila j'ai dormi trois 3 heures par nuit
cette semaine là parce que il a fallu
faire le tournage d'écriture le montage
la voix off c'est un boulot de titan
mais je regrette pas parce que vraiment
ça m'a ça m'a beaucoup appris des
efforts qui vont peut-être finir par
payer aujourd'hui elle a rendez vous
avec un employeur qu'il a directement
contacté
c'est son troisième entretien d'embauché
seulement et ne se sent pas très à
l'aise dans cet exercice
un peu nerveuse mais je ferme mon mieux
pour que pour que ça marche c'est pour
un poste de journaliste pour un grand
site d'information sur internet
marlène la rédactrice en chef l'a
spontanément appelé après avoir vu sa
petite vidéo sur le net
c'est exactement le profil qu'elle
recherchait on cherche quelqu'un
justement pour faire des vidéos un petit
peu dans le style de ce que vous avez
fait dans votre cv c'est à dire quelque
chose un peu décalé un peu drôle
le concept de florence a fait mouche car
comme beaucoup d'employeurs marlène n'a
pas une minute à elle
des cv classique sa boîte mail en est
saturé soit des dizaines de candidatures
par jour candidature et d'actrices
pistre et des journalistes
non je vous dis là je les ai même pas
ouvert on en reçoit trop on en a dix par
jour qui sont en général toutes
présentées de façon très académique le
fait de chercher du travail aujourd'hui
c'est cesser ses limites faudrait faudra
un diplôme qu'un diplôme de chercheurs
d'emploi l'entretien aura duré en tout
une grosse demi heure
oui j'ai un bon feeling voilà j'avais un
bon feeling ça veut pas dire que ça va
marcher mais je n'ai pas d'espoir ça
aux dernières nouvelles marlène a
commandé un film test à florence avant
de peut-être l'engager définitivement la
carrière professionnelle de paul elle
n'a pas toujours été un long fleuve
tranquille
il avait entendu parler des dating pour
trouver une nounou alors lui il a
inventé le dating pour trouver un patron
ancien chômeur paul connaît bien les
difficultés pour obtenir un rendez vous
avec des employeurs c'est comme ça que
lui est venue l'idée de ce nouveau
concept réunir des demandeurs d'emploi
et des chefs d'entreprises autour d'un
café ça marche et la preuve encore une
fois ce matin est démontrée puisque on a
trentaine de candidats dizaine
d'entreprises avec les emplois pour voir
l'entreprise vient elle paye 25 euros
les candidats qui peuvent payer deux
euros et les contacts se font
professionnellement pendant toute la
matinée des rendez-vous qui n'auraient
jamais eu dans d'autres systèmes et
ailleurs alors qu'avec une lettre de
candidature classique ces candidats
auraient mis des semaines pour décrocher
un seul rendez vous avec un employeur
l'a en trois petites heures ils peuvent
enchaîner entretien / entretien
facilement alors qu'un cv c'est une
dernière derrière moi ça va vite tout le
stress au général
préfère les entretiens pour les patrons
aussi c'est du pain bénit recruter un
samedi matin c'est la certitude d'avoir
en face des candidats plus que motivés
matin très clairement il ya un minimum
de profil qui sont intéressants c'est
très humain l'idée est formidable à
messieurs c'est beaucoup mais j'ai déjà
fait rentrer pas mal de personnes dans
ma société grâce aujourd'hui les
pouvoirs publics s'intéressent de très
près aux concepts de paul et même des
pays comme le canada et les états unis
l'ont contacté pour exporter sa méthode
dite des bonnes idées
paul en a 100 la minute sa dernière en
date pour aider les chômeurs à retrouver
rapidement du travail
c'est dans une usine de bouteilles d'eau
que ça se passe a priori aucun rapport
et pourtant pour paul et alain le
directeur de l' usine ça coule de source
des signes de mieux on le rappelle jean
pax matin
dix mille panneaux de limite ses 10000
mini cv dans les articulations dans les
magasins l'idée ingénieuse de paul
insérer les mini cv de 64 chômeurs entre
les bouteilles d'eau le principe est
simple chaque acheteur d'un pack d'eau
est un employeur en puissance
la stratégie donc c'est d'inonder le
maximum de monde dans le monde via des
employeurs ou des emplois qui
connaissent aussi des gens qui ont des
offres d'emploi proposées
et ces gens-là automatiquement rentrer
en contact direct via l'association avec
des candidats potentiels pour leur
éviter des dépassements
depuis que paul a lancé cette opération
il a eu quelques touches mais il y croit
dur comme fer mais en fait ce système
fait surtout les affaires d'alain le
patron de lusine ça lui coûte 7000 euros
par an pour imprimer les cv mais depuis
qu'il fait ça il donne une bonne image
de son entreprise et les ventes se sont
même améliorées bons sont les anges
lorsque même à des augmentations de
misson concentrent dans le cadre
d'animations confessions des magasins
quand on parle de midi c'est l'astuce
elle est là en plus de glisser des cv
dans les packs d'eau alain paye les
demandeurs d'emploi 50 euros pour les
transformer en démonstrateur dans les
supermarchés de la région
dany est d'origine bulgare elle parle
quatre langues elle est bardé de
diplômes
le seul hic c'est qu'elle est au chômage
depuis quatre ans dany fait donc la
promo de cette eau minérale celle là
fait mature vous retrouverez les
oui c'est vrai à l'intérieur danny van
des packs d'eau et en bonus elle peut
vanter les mérites de son cv le numéro
ça permet de faire sa propre promotion
au lieu d'attendre que les institutions
travaillent pour nous et qui cherche qui
nous trouve un travail je trouve la
démarche est beaucoup plus active et on
est beaucoup plus motivés de faire notre
propre promotion
le moyen pour dany d'accrocher la
tension d'employeurs potentiels
et puis bon tout le monde fait ses
courses 1 du directeur de société
à la ménagère tout le monde et vous avez
des contacts pour pour aider
personnellement non malheureusement non
aujourd'hui coup de chance pour notre
commercial ce client n'est pas chef
d'entreprise
mais il a une proposition très
intéressante pour elle si vous savez
vendre deux suivants de vin bière oui
bien sûr encore quand on est dans une
région ça se vendent beaucoup plus
moi je vais je vais voir avec mon
employeur et puis à drh de mon employeur
sait très bien faire parler de soi c'est
essentiel quand on recherche un emploi
et grâce à internet
tout va maintenant beaucoup plus vite
car ce sont des centaines et des
centaines de milliers d'internautes qui
se passent le mot pour yannick miel
tout a commencé ici dans le quartier de
la défense à paris
son nom ne vous dit rien et pourtant en
confident aujourd'hui superbe promotion
sur le jeune diplômé il est passé dans
tous les journaux télévisés il a fait le
buzz comme on dit bien lui en a pris
c'est le ministre martin hirsch en
personne qui l'a embauché comme chargé
de mission
mais avant d'en arriver là où yannick
avait minutieusement préparé son coup
c'était 48 heures après que je me sois
mis en vente sur ebay par provocation en
disant bastille aujourd'hui en tant que
jeunes diplômés j'ai pas de valeur on va
commencer les enchères à 1 euro se
mettre en vente sur internet comme un
vulgaire produit il fallait oser et ça
marche en 48 heures il devient une star
la plaisanterie fonctionne tellement
bien que les enchères fictif vont
grimper jusqu'à 10 millions d'euros un
an plus tard il a retrouvé sans problème
un poste dans une école d'assurance un
grand bureau trois personnes sous ses
ordres et beaucoup de responsabilités
j'aurais peut-être pu arriver à cette
situation si j'avais pas fais mon monde
2 mai serait mis peut-être cinq six ans
de plus moralité quand on veut vraiment
décrocher le boulot de ses rêves il faut
savoir faire preuve d'originalité et
avoir un sacré culot et même ceux qui
finissent par réussir continue à faire
parler d'eux sur le net